the moderna
CEO was testifying for congress for the
Senate and Rand Paul Senator Rand Paul
from Kentucky libertarian as you know on
my short list of same people in
government uh he basically destroyed the
guy this is this is just an absolute
destruction and well watch yourself
is there a higher interest or a higher
incidence of myocarditis among
adolescent males 16 to 24 after taking
your vaccine
so thank you for the questions and
that's all first let me say we care
deeply about safety and we are walking
closely with the CDC and the FDA so
pretty much a yes or no is there a
higher incidence of myocarditis among
boys 16 to 24 after they take your
vaccine I've shown actually I've seen
sorry from the CDC actually shown that
there's less air qualities for people
who get the vaccine versus who get
covered infection you're saying that for
ages 16 to 24 among males who take the
covet vaccine their risk of myocarditis
is less than people who get the disease
that is my understanding that is not
true and I'd like to enter into the
record six peer-reviewed papers from the
Journal of vaccine the annals of
medicine that say the complete opposite
of what you say I also spoke with your
president just last week and he readily
acknowledged in private that yes there
is an increased risk of myocarditis the
fact that you can't say in public is
quite disturbing
so the guy that Rand Paul is talking to
there is the CEO of modernist Stefan
bonsell we'll get to some video of him
in just a second and basically Rand Paul
is like okay you're the CEO you're
testifying here I'm obviously not
getting the truth to you uh but off the
Record in a private conversation uh the
president of moderna he's actually
laying out the goods but if you want to
realize how deep these people are in on
it right they force these vaccines on
everybody they had all these government
organizations pressuring all of us to do
these things we now know the rates of
myocarditis we know all the vaccine
injuries
and even if none of that had existed
even if this vaccine was perfect they
had no right to mandate it government
had no right to force companies to fire
people and all of that stuff that you
know all about but watch this here's
Rand Paul asking Stefan bonsell how many
times his kids have been vaccinated he
doesn't even know the answer
I'm not the clinician I would have to
discuss you have children I do have you
vaccinated your children I have how many
times
three or four times
four times
I mean is that wild relative to
everything that has happened over these
last couple years you have the CEO of a
major pharmaceutical company really the
number two company besides Pfizer as far
as these mRNA vaccines these companies
have made hundreds of millions of
dollars if not billions of dollars and
have all sorts of contracts with all
sorts of governments they force this on
everybody he doesn't even know how many
times off the top of his head he
injected his kids with this stuff yet he
was forcing you to inject your kids with
it
[Music]